I am a free speech Zealot myself I'm a
free speech absolutist I believe that's
part of what it means to be American I
think he's a hero for taking the risk
personal risk that's my definition of
courage is taking a personal risk to
advance your convictions what does that
mean you have convictions and you're
willing to take risks he's done both
those things in trying to turn Twitter
into Free Speech platform I respect it
second thing he's done that I respect
and I think we could use more of this in
our government
is he's completely decimated the
managerial class okay and this is one of
my big themes is you have a managerial
class of bureaucrats in the public and
private sectors that are by the way some
of the same people okay associate Deans
at universities to Mid to upper level
management at Twitter to the deputy
under Secretary of whatever whatever to
some Ambassador I think he has
completely taken that managerial layer
out of Twitter personally I think it's
what the us next U.S president needs to
do to the federal bureaucratic alphabet
soup as well so those are all things
that I think he gives us a model for
inspiration the model for hope I take
inspiration from it I agree with all of
it